-Finn is sort of a budding sta
in his own right.
He has an Instagram page.
-Yes he is. Absolutely.
-And, again, this Instagra
page, you get gold like this
-That's his own hair.
-What?
-His own hair.
-No, it's not.
-Yes it is. It's itching season.
I don't know if you guys hav
dogs, but he's really moltin
and matting
and all these weird terms
that I didn't know existed
And his hair's just falling out.
So you have to brush him a lot
And that's --
Actually, I keep it.
What I do is, I wash it, and
then I have a spinning wheel
and I'm learning
how to spin fibers into yarn
And that is absolutely
what I'm doing,
and I'm going to make somethin
out of his fur.
-And then I'm assuming
after that you'll become
a serial killer?
-I don't know
what's next for me.
But, you know,
a world of possibilities.
-I feel like if you, like,
broke into a suspect's house
and there was, like,
a knitting wheel
and, like, dog hair, you'd b
like, "This is the killer.
-"This is where they work.
This is where they work."
-This is -- Now, is this
real, too? Did you --
-Yeah. That's Frankie.
Franklin, the Russian tortoise
-Okay. And so you can just put
a turtle on your dog's head,
and he's fine?
-You name it.
You can put it on his head
A dog. You can find the smallest
dog, put it on his head.
I swear it would work.
-And this is very thematic
So, you have a farm.
You have a lot of animals.
-Yeah.
-And I guess
this is a horse and --
-It's a donkey.
-That's a donkey wearing a hat
-Yeah.
-This seems to be thematic
of you and your photos.
-Listen. As long as
they seem fine about it.
-Yeah. You have chickens.
-I do have chickens.
-And do you eat
your chickens' eggs?
-I eat the eggs almost daily
-Is it the best?
-They're the best.
They're the best.
I mean, you don't even need to
like, use butter or oil.
They're just so delicious.
It feels so good to be abl
to make your own --
Like, I could survive
a little bit on the farm
if the world were to end.
-Yeah.
-And that makes me really happy.
-Yeah. You would just --
You'd have your eggs
in the morning,
and at night get under
your dog blanket
that you knitted yourself.
-Exactly. That's exactly right
I mean, how great --
My dog will always be around
Always.
-That's very good.
I -- I do think there's
something exciting about -
How many eggs --
I'm sorry for being ignorant
Do you go out every day to
check to see if there are eggs
-Yeah, because you have to ope
their -- You have to have --
To be a responsible
chicken owner,
you have to close them up
at night.
-'Cause the -- Whatever the --
-'Cause they party. Yeah.
-Yeah. You never know.
Get behind a wheel.
You don't know
what they're going to do.
You got to lock them in.
So we do that.
And then in the morning,
I open it up before I feed
-And how many chickens
do you have?
-Seven right now. One rooster.
-Okay. So six hens.
-And so on a normal day,
how many eggs can you get
in the morning?
-Right now,
'cause it depends on the season,
oddly enough, right now
we get, like, three a day.
-Alright. That's not bad.
-Different colors, too.
Not that it matters. Same taste.
Different colors.
-Yeah. But that's exciting
-So exciting 'cause --
I like to -- I see it, and I'm
like, "I should Instagram this."
I hate that that's
where my mind goes now.
"I should Instagram this."
I mean, you should make it loo
really cool.
-Yeah, but you should just b
in the moment with your eggs
-I'm not. -That's my problem
And you know what?
My daughter is starting to say
"Put down your phone.
Put your phone down."
Do your kids do that?
-My kids want to look
at the phone.
'Cause they don't --
So they, like,
watching videos of themselves.
-Yeah. Totally. Yeah.
-'Cause they're like --
Basically for them,
it's like this piece --
It's like a movie
that they're the star of
every day.
But they haven't told me
to put down the phone yet.
They're always like,
"Put down the drink."
Like, that's, you know...
-Well, at least
they're watching out for you
-Yeah.
-Already.
-That's great.
-I want to -- you also --
My father-in-law had a pet goa
that sadly passed away.
You have a goat
that looks, uh, dumb.
I feel like people might think
I'm mean right now,
but I'm going to
show this picture,
and hopefully people agree
This looks like a dumb goat.
-It's a perfect example
of another moment
where I was not in the moment.
-You were not in the moment.
-And I was definitely taking
this picture for Instagram
-Yeah, but, I mean,
what's the moment?
Live in the moment. Look
at his butthole and his dumb..
Just don't make this
about social media.
Be with the goat's butthole.
-But it was the tongue
that really got me.
-The tongue is pretty great.
-I was hoping people
wouldn't notice that
it was a butthole shot.
It was really a tongue sho
veiling a butthole shot.
Because really, what's --
-Yeah, you should use the crop
function on your...
That's also a photo.
-No, but I wanted to get awa
with it, so I did it.
My God. I'm a terrible person.
-Hey, thanks so much
for coming back...
-That poor goat.
Thanks for having me.
-...and sharing
all your animal stories.
Always good to catch up
with Finn and his friends.
Amanda Seyfried, everybody